2020 roundup here we come Kamala Harris
ramping up her attacks to silence the
president after complaining about
Trump's tweets she sent a letter to
Twitter CEO begging for the president's
account to be suspended Juan don't you
think this kind of just looks a weak no
they should have suspended as a count
long ago and for breaking the rules but
Twitter is a private company yeah Jesse
they can set any rules they want I mean
you know it's not a matter of your First
Amendment rights or anything so clear
they don't plan to suspend the president
would be so politically explosive his
base would say oh what a grievance
they're always picking on the right
they're always picking on Trump get out
of here but anyway that's not gonna
happen
very clear I will say that I think
Harris is trying to stir her pace you
know Elizabeth Warren went after
Facebook and then sucker went after her
and now I think that what you get is
Kamala Harris saying I think I can go
after Twitter because there's a lot of
anger at big tech going into 2020 I see
it as a gimmick I mean they're never
gonna suspend ya its Zuckerberg by the
way different different major company
it's desperation to Kamala Harris is
fumbling and she's like oh I'm gonna go
after Twitter because Elizabeth Warren
has sucked all the oxygen out of the
room she's standing up and saying I'm
gonna go after Facebook I'm gonna break
them up I'm gonna go after all of these
big technology companies maybe by
sucking up to some of these technology
companies , Harris thinks she can get
some money from him well she got some
airtime on fox well I thought we covered
it was when she knocked out Joe is right
so she's got to try to figure out some
way to punch through the news cycle and
I guess this was it it's very strange to
me to have someone who is running to be
President of the United States that
wants to silence another human being
that's a fellow citizen besides his
tweeting is like their best asset what
are they that guy just wit you know I
wish you wouldn't tweet I mean if he if
he stops tweeting what are they gonna
run against that's a good point
Greg what would we do for at least she
has come a long way very good thank you
very much i if you can't beat him you
ban him he has the best Twitter game
whether you like him or not the best
Twitter game in history he does things
that has never been done before and
probably never be done again so her
argument is absurd especially when you
have Maxine Waters saying that she wants
you know Trump to be put in solitary
confinement or something people are
saying terrible things about everybody
Trump's just way better at it and he's
got a hot new tweet right now about Joe
Biden I direct everybody in the audience
to look at that after Bernie Sanders
canceling future campaign events while
he recovers from a health scare the
senator underwent a heart procedure
yesterday after experiencing chest
discomfort testing found he had a
blockage in an artery and his campaign
says he is in good spirits and we wish
the senator a speedy recovery
Gregg is 78 years old you know he's got
a lot of energy but I think this came as
a surprise everybody he's I think he's
is he 2 years younger or 2 years older
than Mick Jagger 3 years older so you
could say he's a stent fighting-man I
have nothing to say
illnesses are inevitable when you get
older and you have 3 contenders right
now that are over 17 ones nearly 80 but
I know it's considered a bad taste to
talk about people's health so I won't
until the break you know it's also bad
taste to talk about the political
implications of this but I mean there
are political and there were some that
his campaign made right away so he will
be off the trail for a little while they
haven't said exactly when I'll come back
but probably given that this is a pretty
routine procedure probably pretty
quickly but he did have one point six
million dollars of ads that were
supposed to go up today starting today
in Iowa they have pulled those for now
oh wow and he just raised a massive
amount of money in the third quarter
long right so we got to wish him well I
mean it's not easy and the funny thing
about this is anytime a man or woman is
running for president you want to know
about their health because you want to
know about any underlying conditions and
I don't think that is a totally a
function of his age you know I've seen
very young people just the other day
someone I know well had to have this
done and it it you know it comes as a
shock because it reminds you of your
mortality the other thing is his
campaign as you point has been doing
well and Beyond raising but it has had
some trouble internally people not
getting along and alike
and of course Elizabeth Warren on fire
all right diggin doesn't have to go to
kind of government-run health of health
institution not yet at least
I'd say that well I think as a senator
he probably has excellent health care we
didn't he tweeted they're very good care
yeah all right O'Rourke took us to the
dentist
then he live-streamed the trip to the
barber to get a haircut then he showed
us all how to change a tire now
Beto's at with a new public service
announcement watch they can actually
think this is his best one because you
want people to see you getting a flu
shot because you want everybody to get
the flu shot yes he's so benevolent
number one do some push-ups before you
show your guns they'll let me see those
arms again yeah busy like driving a car
and not working out number one number
two you know I get stuff shot in my face
at least once every four weeks of
needles so this is really not that big
deal one you're terrified of needles
aren't you are you okay because you know
what I don't cuz it's face work and I'm
50 and I work on TV and I don't care if
anybody knows that you're looking lovely
kid but anyway I I just got a flu shot
and my pal Dana got a flu shot and then
because I'm over 65 they gave me a
pneumonia shot which I didn't ask for
and I've just been feeling low but so
anyway gets good thing it's a good thing
for him to do that I know you guys are
going to do it as political but it's all
part of his act about I'm a real human
being and that sells just ask Donald
Trump well I like the dentist one better
well look I would say that his stunts
getting a flu shot to get on TV is
better than Kamala Harris trying to ban
President Trump on Twitter if you are
judging by those two things today flu
shot my husband and I did it as a date I
think I think it was covered by well I
guess you pay
just be happy he didn't get an enema
okay